phineas went to a karate class one time
he loved this karate class so much like
you could see the light in his eyes end
of the class the teacher goes all right
at this studio we have a ritual we
always have a student of the day and my
heart sank i was like oh no oh no
phineas is going to be the student of
the day i know it because he was new it
ruined it because all he now cared about
was oh my gosh i was student of the week
oh my gosh i got the the headband i'm
going to be the student of the week
again next week and then the next week
he's like why wasn't i a student of the
week this week mom well they give it to
a girl different kid every day every
week he goes yeah but i really worked
hard and i was the best but that's not
what it's about the reward became the
external prize before they had the
reward he loved the class the reward is
making the music the reward is learning
the the thing you know you get to this
place where now it becomes about record
sales it becomes about this becomes
about that and the joy always has to go
back to the doing it's always about the
doing